scott téléthon gérard oui allez-y les
copains de la nuit il à tous ceux qui
regardent antenne 2 le soir plutôt que
de regarder des feuilletons américains
ou des ou des séries ou des choses comme
ça sur les autres chaînes vous nous avez
rejoint vous faites partie de la famille
du téléthon emma profitez-en vous fait
36 37 vous appelez j'ai avec moi de
super chanteur gilberto gil on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure nick nicole
croisille l'eau si je me suis permis
mais quelle audace de sortir ma guitare
de mon étui parce que je voudrais qu'on
fasse pour ce téléthon soleil je
voudrais qu'on qu'on essaie
d'interpréter pour vous ça va être
facile pour moi ça va être autre chose
une chanson qui est pour moi un symbole
de la lutte contre le racisme qui est
une chanson toute simple de serge
gainsbourg qui s'appelle couleur café je
m'étais planter lamentablement il ya
deux ans parce que j'avais pas réussi
dans le téléthon elle a chanté je me
suis pas vraiment non je me suis pas
vraiment aidé à milan avec vous ça ira
mieux
tél
j'aime ta couleur café
tes grands yeux café tagore jeu café
j'aime le camp pour moi tu danses alors
j'entends murmuré
toutes tes bras se lèvent
joli bracelet mme à tes pieds ils se
balancent couleurs
café
ce que j'aime ta couleur car les
couleurs
t
et que jamais la couleur
hier cours c'est quand même fou les
faits
l'effet que ça fait un devoir dont les
racines ainsi des yeux et des enjeux si
tu fais comme le café rien kamenar wen
rien qu'à nice
ce soir la nuit sera change de couleur
café
que je veux ta couleur café couleur café
ce que je veux
car elle avoue
à giverny
m
tout l'air
un café
que je me tape le
car voilà merci c'est réussi je suis
allé c'est bien que flatté
un problème de santé une chose si ce
moment ce sont les miracles il faudra
pas non si un petit peu quand même
les miracles du téléthon j'ai même
réussi à jouer de la guitare merci
gilberto merci nicole merci chantal on
va accueillir maintenant un copain
africain